we always do this at the end of P daily
um there is a surprise Reddit story um
we were just having a conversation
before the show nazarin didn't know what
Reddit is so I think I've now got you up
to date yeah it's just a forum people
tell their stories and uh yeah we get to
read those stories so let's take a look
my boyfriend and I have been dating for
over a decade and I genuinely love him
he is the nicest person I know but due
to some differences between US during
the past few months I used sex with
other people as an outlet and cheated on
him he found out and broke up with me
and I fully understand and respect his
decision I'm seriously not this type of
person and I am a good human being I
just happen to do something bad his
mother and I have been close for a long
time she absolutely adores me and I love
her too we have a very close
relationship she has taught me how to
knit and I have taught her how to make
presentations and stuff we Bond really
well we really close and I asked my ex
if he could hide my cheating it is
something between me and him and no no
one else needs to know about it
thankfully he agreed and told his mom
that we had an amicable breakup due to
Mutual differences I still visit his mom
at times and he ignores me which hurts a
lot but he is friendly enough at times
and even Smiles at me when I'm around
his mother I explained to my friend the
complex situation I'm in and she told me
that I'm being an [__] by letting my
ex not have any room to vent since he
has told everyone that it was an
amicable breakup and we are still
friends honestly it was a mutual
decision and he agreed to it so I do not
think I've done anything wrong when it
comes to keeping it between ourselves
would love a fresh perspective thanks
this
is crazy I feel like when someone really
needs to justify that they're a good
person chances are they probably
not if you if you have to constantly say
I I promise I'm good mhm chances are
you've done a lot of stuff that would
suggest that you're not now we don't
know this lady really and truly this is
all we know but from this I I would not
class her as a good person um and I
actually think that she is surrounded by
by amazing friends because the friends
have told her the truth the friends have
said you're being a dick yeah you've
you've put him in a position where he
has to lie to everyone about what's
actually happened he can't get the
emotional support that he probably needs
during this very distressing time and
you're being out of order and what a
great friend to tell her that because
how many friends in this day and age
would actually be that brutal and honest
with you usually it's like you go girl
we done for cheating whoever this girl
is you you've got an amazing friend the
friend who said this to you is a keep
her around because that is a very good
friend I'm sorry this isn't an accident
because it wasn't just once I used sex
with other people people people what so
it wasn't an accident it's not a mistake
like if it just happened once I would be
much more um not I mean not
understanding because I still don't
understand it but I'd be a little bit
more understanding but the fact it's
like multiple people I just can't it's
not accident also this whole thing is
about her you know there is nothing
about him so the only thing that she
actually mentions as to why this
happened um because I think we all know
like if a woman cheats chances are that
that's because something was was going
wrong for well down the line and then
she's instead of being an adult about it
and bringing it up she she's gone and
cheated on him because she's not able to
have a conversation about things but you
know she just seems to be
overcompensating for lot he is the
nicest person I know but due to some
differences between US during the past
few months she doesn't then go to
clarify what those differences are she
doesn't tell us what's actually happened
she she wants a fresh perspective
actually what I think she wants is to be
reinforced that don't worry you're a
good person because she didn't get that
from the friend so now she's come on the
internet and aired out her dirty laundry
gross because she wants someone online
to to do it for her instead of just
accepting no I messed up I've been awful
I'm very ashamed of myself I should
probably fix myself to make sure I don't
hurt someone like this in the future um
again the whole middle section is just
about her relationship with his mom
she's not even recognizing what her
friend is saying she's literally come
online and told the internet what her
friend is saying and she can't even say
you know what I see I do see what she's
saying there's no acknowledgement or
responsibility here no but also if you
love him and you love his mom and you
love being around his family why did you
cheat on him because you
know I mean you would know that he's
going to a that to them and if you have
that much respect but he hasn't even
been able to do that I know exactly but
he probably would have if she didn't
tell him not to like it's so there's
something not right there she's put her
own relationship with a guy's
mother before his relationship also he's
not being strong enough to be like no
yeah you know I completely agree F off
you did this to me I'm now going to cut
you out of my life and
people deserve know what you're why why
is he even allowing her around his mom
knowing that she's got the capability to
hurt people like that no that's very
true manipulate people that's very true
no he needs to completely get this girl
out of his life completely they're both
in the wrong yeah they are both in the
wrong it's just I guess my heart just
goes out to him because he's already
been through so much um but no you are
completely right he needs to completely
B this guy off and get her out of his
life just straight up tell the mom cuz I
can guarantee you the mom would not be
having this relationship with her she
knew what what actually happened so it's
almost like he's joining in on the
manipulating yeah he's almost hurting
himself further by allowing this to
happen and his mom because it's it's
ultimately a lie isn't it yeah anyway we
have an edit on this story so she's come
back to give us all an update I feel
like a lot of you are calling me a bad
person because I cheated oh my God what
people are calling you a bad person cuz
you cheated how could you how could they
if my boyfriend broke up with me I think
I have suffered the
consequences I am a good person and I
try to be a better one each day it's
complicated I genuinely want opinions on
the mutual decision my boyfriend and I
made not to tell his mother I did beg
and plead but in the end it was an
agreement from both sides so I did use
my tactics of feminine manipulation
which we all know are the the tears and
the I'm just a a weak frail little girl
that that doesn't know any better so not
only have I manipulated him into a
situation um but I'm also going to sit
here and say that it was
Mutual
what
look guy if you happen to come across
this and see us reading this story
please get rid of her please tell your
mom please tell your mom tell your mom
please tell your mom she'll get rid of
her for you she if you are not in the
position to be a man right now that is
what your mom is for yeah use her it's
just like I understand people are flawed
like yeah we sin we we make mistakes but
not multiple times like it's multiple
people she's cheated with it's not that
that's the thing everyone has come back
and said that she's a bad person and
instead of listening obviously to
everyone this this is how you know that
that a lot of modern women are
narcissistic because
if loads of people are screaming
something at you chances are it's true
it's true
so instead of coming back to edit and
try and justify again I'm still a good
person why are you all saying I'm not
maybe you should look and go oh [__]
maybe I [__] up
here but no the
delusion wins again yeah so much
delusion it's actually hard to it's hard
to live in this Society where and
everyone's just like it seems like
everyone's crazy but you sometimes yeah
yeah and that's why it's great to have
you here in a room because you remind me
that there are other people who are not
completely bewildered with delusion